immédiatement cela par ces relations ce
type vous avez la parole
stop
le même esprit mais c'est bien triste
pour la zone euro l'union européenne
dans les sommets hamas assassiné trouve
quelques jours ce soit en effet choisi
de s'exprimer pour dépasser le symbole
et non pas fait de manière inégale mais
aussi de trouver sous contrôle et les
mêmes qu'avec chevet et tenter comme
solution wing lovibond à mamie tu es
condamné c'est bien vers la kaaba
judicieux avec et prospère ce soit une
campagne mais dire ok et damien peut le
guérir ce même lobby
matt damon je suis heureux d'être ici ou
là ou d'entendre cela potager qui sont
si je voulais dire donc prête mais c'est
pas de chasse de la rupture avec des
sirènes caisse les sauver ceux qui sont
des principes mais sa tête je veux pas
notre europe et est repris à langer
éphémère démocratique et intégration
c'est dit c'est fait alors elle aura
beaucoup de mal à nous de leur temps
plein et entier du maine beau mais nous
sommes au stade ramat a nécessité
environ
mais les plans de sauvetage n'ont pas il
ya cinq mois y est mes gardiens
mais écoutez deux troupes à sa source
dans le sens où tout ce qui fait le jeu
avec ça on peut voir le bien-fondé la
grogne a justement été ces dernières
années et puissance évidemment je
respecte par ces points séparent n'ont
été aussi longs qu'ils ont été un champ
d'expérimentation de vous tuer
nous devons bien voir la face
l'expérience cinq dernières
l'effeuillage la pauvre aujourd'hui une
majorité il faut qu'ils aient fait mieux
la plus démocratique
maintenant concrétiser ce faux mais
heureusement grecque
un accord signé le contrat suppose la
douleur les travailleurs et retraités
par tout ce qui symbolise 15 à 20 ans tu
deviens supporter ces années le mois
hanemaayer suisse aboutir à la
croissance et d'orangés pressées
entreprises des meilleurs mais c'était
une proposition des socialistes et essai
et des sessions voir la réalité en face
et ses caractéristiques à proposer
souple 6 mars nous présentons nous
allons faire
c'est sa ptc se trouve à la sortie de 18
mètres pour la maria ceaucescu estime
plan de sauvetage qui a expiré franges
et joseph pas comme un rire de ce cadeau
manière navrant c'est mr depuis toujours
par le mois d'août est donc ici à
nettoyer paris s'il n'était pas
à croquer tout simplement qu'il vient
consensus pour réalisable saisir un
monde assez tôt sa compagnie sur la
période et gvt relève tech sur le dos
des été tué le suspense situation c'est
parce que pendant des décennies sein de
gouvernements successifs
on avait des gars né de façon à tester
sonne évidemment
musique la fraude sera réduit
d'après le crédit bien qu'ils étaient
des colonies des richesses ils n'ont pas
contribué
les 80 cm et non pas capoter améliorer
le fonctionnement particulier comme en
attestent ses propres histoires de
risque de se piquer mais heureusement
eric aime à se propager ce week end
ronde
c'est pratique mais vous pouvez booster
on a l'habitude d'arriver là reconnaît
mme dati messi
qui était son fournisseur
nous attendons la caméra ordinaire la
misère commentaire mais les deux nicolau
tous importants de la grèce et qui sont
en train d'enfoncer le rosier guérir la
thèse développée
messieurs les députés la grèce et
apporter les chemins
je serai l'un des fils de la zone euro à
trouver une solution de crise de
l'endettement qui me saute pas de battre
pour tester des questions qui est bel et
bien avant cela il faut une solution
européenne
il crée en europe c'est gros c'est une
histoire mais qui est bien
une histoire de convergys
cette unité est pas y avoir de là mais
c'est bien pour laquelle marc médine a
fini lui nuire mais nous dénonçons ces
honorables pour une rupture nous de
notre côté à prendre nos responsabilités
avec nous
trilingue
il incarne
c'est passé